Twitter CEO Jack Dorsey says he has no  reason to ban radio host and conspiracy  theorists Alex Jones even though other  tech giants have Apple Facebook YouTube  Spotify Pinterest and LinkedIn have all  removed material from Jones and his  infowar site they claimed he violated  policies against hate speech  Jones denies that and says the decisions  were about censoring conservative  content when Twitter was criticized for  not banning Jones Dorsey says he will be  held accountable but quote has not  violated our rules endorsees words if we  succumb and simply react to outside  pressure rather than straightforward  principles we become a service that's  constructed by our personal views